hi Chris Garlock here with Michael
Redmond for the match highlights in the
fifth and final game of the google
deepmind challenge michael lisa doll had
won Game four snatching victory from the
jaws of defeat and came into this final
game with a pretty clear game plan yet
explain what the plan was and had worked
there were already signs of it I think
from game number two okay but at first
Lee SEDOL was just playing it with white
kind of a hamachi strategy like taking
territory and then invading them Moyo
which is usually played with white but
in this game he was playing it with
black and I was sort of I did before see
that sort of I was thinking maybe he
would do it but since it's usually not a
strategy that's played with black I was
sort of not quite sure whether it would
play for territory as he did we can
already see that black is taking
territory in two corners and playing a
opening this very oriented towards
territory all right but still maybe he
would try a fighting style opening which
didn't really work in the first game
right and it didn't work in the third
game either so I think in the fourth
game he really decided that he could
take territory and exploit the weakness
maybe of alphago by invading the Moyo
and getting into a complicated fight
there so after all it was the game plan
in this game - I was sort of expecting
it but I wasn't sure so I was interested
to see him actually using this plan it's
a bit unusual for white to ignore this
but white is playing for the whole board
so it's maybe a valid way for white to
play white plays the honey this is the
strongest attack and with this move
white is basically already thinking of
just sacrificed sure zones so black
extends my place there now White has a
base here black has a nice territory
here
locally it's quite a success for black
why did get the extra move here which is
going to influence the area here and
white has sent a so I'd put one stone
here in return black has a very nice
territory here there is the point that
it's it he already had a solid territory
so he's just building on a solid
territory which is not the most
efficient thing but I would be happy to
be playing with black yeah and you like
there's a little of territory yeah
and then black slides this is also a
natural move and white pincers this is a
pincer to make influence in this area
with this behind it so this is a very
natural move if white had played in the
corner like this it would have been just
perfect for black to extend here making
a stable group in the place where white
had hoped to make some well if not
territorial oil at least so white plays
here at this point Lisa L played this
move which I I sort of doubt actually
it's a it's hard to say which is better
but since the latter is good for black I
would have probably just played here and
if white plays here black can connect
underneath and the honey the ladder here
is good for black so white will either
play here or sometimes you see players
play this some but in that case black
gets this leaves a lot of potential for
these two black stones to move out later
in the game there's still the invasion
in the 3-3 point here so I would be
happy to play with black in this opening
an actual game black gave some territory
back to white by playing this and
pulling back this move basically makes
me I or me I are interchangeable points
so either that move which is where white
played or if white plays on this side
but if black will play here white
extends and again this this shape is
kind of a double extension from the star
point and it's sort of inefficient when
black jumps into the 3gc
so this is more or less what black was
aiming at so it was correct for white to
play on this side
and allow black to cut and in this safe
black has slightly more thickness
compared to this shape which is a common
joseki black has more thickness towards
the center but white has these extra
stones here which sort of form some
extra territory here so black has lost
some territory in return for this double
this line of stones here but you're
facing towards just facing towards the
center so he's sort of afraid of a sin
turmoil a little bit it's not really
consistent with his plan to take as much
territory as possible so that's why I
sort of questioned this move but it is a
kind of a balanced play here then white
plays on top here this is a not natural
follow-up move for this whole shape the
throwing away because it's sort of
planning to squeeze using the odd G of
these stones maybe not the connection
but at least squeeze black reduce
Black's territory well building on the
center so it's a very natural move and
so black resists a little bit and push
through once yeah and now black points
out to the left that reduces Weiss
potential in this area of the board a
great deal now something odd happens
something odd happens is this clear
cutter cut first cuts for the whole
sequence here just to point it out in
the beginning the whole sequence here
will end up with black being very very
strong in this area so the drawback of
white sequence is that White's going to
make very black very solid here and that
makes a difference when white place
moves like this or it moves like in the
game white chose this one
in either case there's an entry point
here okay and so I would calculate
White's loss on this side to be about
five points when white plays starts
playing moves like this here and here
and here and white connected play to
honey and we can see the back to listen
getting stronger and stronger and none
of this works it doesn't work actually
white is gaining
a couple of points on this side a few
points on the side so it depends on
really how on how you count the game
that black has on this side which i
think is pretty bad but if for instance
if this becomes blacks territory or if
nothing special happens here then there
is a slight gain for white on this side
so it is it sort of depends on how the
game continues in some cases this is not
going to be a loss at all the general
idea is that White's lost so much on
this side but usually it's bad for white
but we can't really be a hundred percent
sure yet at this point so sometimes this
doesn't have such a terrible impact on
the game there was a little concern when
this was being played during the game
that maybe alphago was going on tilt a
little bit again well I didn't think so
and well the local moves makes sense and
even if you assume that it was a genuine
mistake it would be a mistake such as
the mistake in the center after the
white move 78 in his fourth game right
where maybe alphago didn't have the
capacity to to read one of the moves
that was a low profile so of course the
programmers will be able to dig into the
program and find that out later and then
after this white place here this is a
standard sequence here throwing one
stone away like this just to get the
extra forcing moves on the outside to
reduce blacks territory like this is
more or less forced and white can play
an Atari on the top and then Atari on
the side so by sacrificing this one
stone white gets some extra forcing
moves and a nice wall there now at this
point black has something in the
vicinity of 40 points here okay about 10
points here more than 10 points there so
well-well slightly over 60 points a lot
of cash and so it's all become solid
territory things it's not gonna well
this is actually if you only count the
very solid territory slightly less than
40 points but in either cases he's black
as in the vicinity of 60 points so
listos planners kind of working he's got
white to create this big Moya and he's
not going to jump in I guess and
this is not really territory yet because
black can jump in here white has some
territory here
and some territory here all of whites
territory doesn't really add up to more
than 30 points at this point so black
has a huge advantage in territory and he
played here which was probably a mistake
this turned out to be a bit deep one
would hope that white would be answering
something like this in which case black
could jump and it would really
completely reduce White's potential in
this whole area and even if white made
some territory in the corner here it
would be good enough for black to win
and this works nicely with rock solid
group and we're sort of seeing if you
assume that white is continuing to try
to take territory you can see that the
center is just disappearing right nicely
right this would be too easy right
so actually what blacks should have done
this blacks should not have being so
greedy maybe and played something closer
to the center which would be not as
effective when white compared to the
diagram I just showed the variation that
is sewed but it's much more safe this
white really can't it's more difficult
for white to break in through there
if white it and let next black does
happen very nice move here which puts
pressure on the corner if white plays
something like that this move alone
without even following it up is already
reduced White's territory here and it's
very difficult for a white to
successfully attack now because black
can sort of just dodge away and treat it
very lightly it's a move on the top for
a move below very difficult for white to
surround it now so black and even black
has a choice then he could play another
move towards the center or it could jump
in here which is a very big territorial
move mm-hmm so this would be I think
this is a slight advantage for black
this move it looked really natural but
if you assume moves like this or moves
like this it's easy for black but the
move white played this capping move
looks very very good it's a move that
actually human players would play too
it's not as if it's especially a
computer move but it's just perfect for
this it's an example of alphago strength
so anyone who is afraid that alphago
would sort of gold desert at this point
should be relieved of that worry and by
seeing this move and I think your
analysis and comment rate was a alpha
doe really just plays this whole
sequence it's very nice sort of good
style we might say it's very natural
moves and white didn't even try to kill
black for instance at this point if
white had played here this would have
been a more serious attempt to kill the
black right and it would entail some
danger because after this there would be
the cut here later and white stones in
this area are not so strong that means
that that could possibly use that to
sort of move out into the center and
this move would be rather small as far
as territory is concerned so it was
probably a wise way for white to play
just to play on the top and and sort of
make this the width of this area thicker
black plays the key point and yes and
now black is alive white continues to
sort of squeeze black and now it's
completely now there's no doubt that
this black group is alive and white
plays on top again again it's good that
you see that white is not connecting
mm-hmm
connecting is a bit heavy actually once
white has forced black to live here you
can say that these two stones are not
really all that important it's not that
White's
I'm going to give them up too easily
sure but in some cases white can afford
to throw them away so they're not as
important as they were before and white
plays on the outside Oh actually I think
black played once here first and then
lived but it's the same thing to move
white plays on the top the point is
white gets a big this is already looking
almost like territory I think if we
added one white move it would be
territory of close to fifty points and
so black had to come in and white still
had potential on the side ins in this
area and that this territory is very
difficult to count actually because it
can be
it could it decreases with every time
black plays have moved there mm-hmm
but it's also it takes some time for
black to get rid of the whole territory
so it's a becomes a very difficult
endgame to execute and very close
already at this point and I think
towards the end it was a half point
difference at some point but Lisa to
lust a little bit alpha go after it's
when was clinched I think it did play
some questionable moves but again it's a
question of it was winning anyway so
maybe it was just playing the safer
route so there's this game from here and
you were accounting and the score it was
really interesting because there was a
lot of moves there were some swaps but
in the in the end the score didn't
really change for a really long time
much all the time it was something like
seven eight points on the board so it's
really really close right lot I was it
was a great we thought we're actually
gonna have a countable game yeah well it
was comfortably wooden County just a
bother because it was I think it the it
was a it was up like a point and a half
one and a half points yes line so well
yet another amazing game I want to say
thank you to you Michael for you know
all of your just incredible analysis
these game commentaries they were all
just exciting and tough games appreciate
that and congratulations again to the
entire alphago team and to lisa doll
this was an amazing week really
appreciate the attention to go i think
it's really gonna as you said open up a
new era for the game for players and for
artificial intelligence so we look
forward to that so i look for the next
time i see you across the board and
thanks everybody for watching hope you
enjoyed thank you